hello everyone and welcome to another
image Medina of game to brighten your
day I hope you enjoyed the previous one
it's a game played in 1948 in a
medallion championship in Kishinev and
Rashid it has the white pieces against a
person called V Baskin this is the only
game in the database rebus can ever
played
so as usual we don't have any data for
such a player that's why there's the
hoodie again and in the honor of the
hoodie guy I am again doing a video also
wearing a hoodie so without further ado
let's try and brighten our day a rush it
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for sorry about that with E for I will
have B 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 the Italian game brush up
to c5 and here Rasheed goes for not the
Evans gambit rather he goes for castles
the the standard Joko piano game Knight
to f6 we have d for the dude's gambit
and once I want to play something like
this you know that he really either
either he considers himself to be much
stronger than you or he really he really
does try to create something like a
Rashid did here you don't want to
capture the pawn with the e pawn that
just ruins your pawn structure you don't
want to capture with the night as this
leaves your a five point vole nerve also
nice captures and if I would come so
basically what you can do is say ok
that's a free pawn I'm just gonna grab
it by shal captures before but you know
the downside to this is that you lose
the bishop pair so ok Knight capture
some before and I capture some before
and now f4 okay we have b6 f captures on
e5 pawn captures on e5 and now Bishop to
g5 already with a double attack on the
night and although castling would be a
bit risky here as you do now you know a
face or opening of the G file but
perhaps it's it's not all that bad but
Queen to e7 followed by developing of
the bishop who would have been better
and tried to cast on the Queen side here
c6 was played it's not it's not a
terrible move but it's a it's a waste of
time here Rasheed plays Queen to
three getting the Queen out of the way
as Bishop to g4 was coming and now black
has to decide what to do black continues
again with the Bishop to g4 trying to
create some room in the Queen set and
perhaps Castle queenside Rashid keeps on
developing pieces if if black castles
here then surely Rashid would have
opened the the the G file with Bishop
captures but he doesn't here probably
want to play h6 either for sir sheet to
capture here see what it does if he cap
if he does then you capture here and try
to go Queen side if he goes back then
you're you get some breathing space here
b5 was played but like in more fees
night at the opera b5 simply won't to do
here image Medina played Queen to g3 and
Queen to g3 is a quite a complicated
move if you just think about it if you
capture the bishop for example Bishop
captures then you leave your night here
Vaughn then you go I can simply capture
and you leave your the Bishop is no
longer defended Queen captures on e5
doesn't really work that great because
night simply blocks and here you don't
really have anything we have Bishop
captures pawn captures rope captures and
after Queen d4 check the Queen's are now
exchanged captures captures and at at
the end of the line a white white is
simply down a whole bishop so after this
Bishop captures on c4 if black accepts
this
then comes the Bishop captures on f6
simply removing the defender of the
Bishop on g4 Queen b6 check out Queen b6
in preparing a discovery not grabbing
material immediately but Queen to b6
this is this is what you have to play
and now after Queen captures on g4 now
you have to find h5 this is the way to
play this Queen moves and only now pawn
captures and now you see that you know
everything is fine on the board black
defended but it's very hard to define
all of these ideas so uh Bishop captures
and pawn captures and c4 was not played
rather we have Queen to b6 immediately
now threatening discoveries we have
Bishop to e3 and the now comes the Queen
to c5 capturing the Bishop here
doesn't work now because of Queen
captures on e5 bushel blocks you can
block with the night because the night
is now pinned Bishop e6 Bishop captures
now you can simply grab it Queen moves
and now after Queen to g3 preventing
castles if castles then Bishop captures
here
white black would have to cast a queen
side and then have to rotate to d1 okay
the material is even but you know blacks
King is very vulnerable black white is
controlling this agonal the B file is
it's a semi-open file so white would
enjoy playing disposition very much
after Bishop to e3 Queen to c5 now
threatening to grab our he is a bishop
on c4 and here Rasheed played a
brilliant move here I'm not even going
to ask you to pause the video and find
it just try to imagine a Rashid move
here a Rashid played Bishop to d5 Bishop
to d5 is a very nice move as the Queen
is no longer protecting the e5 phone so
now the threat is of course Queen
captures on e5 you can't capture the
bishop with the knight then you you're
no longer defending the bishop on g4 and
what happens after C captures on d5 well
Queen captures on d5 now that you've
captured the Queen is also no longer
guarding the pawn Queen moves and now
Bishop captures on d4 as the knight is
undefended
captures captures we have captures
captures captures captures and after all
is said and done the material on the
board is equal but White has a much
better pawn structure two points Black
has three point islands and the black
also has a double deaf pawn so a better
position for white definitely so after
Bishop to d5 mr. V Baskin decided to go
for queenside castle we have rook
captures on f6 now removing the defender
of the bishop on g4 pawn captures and
Queen captures on g4 which check we have
f5 and now the Queen must capture on f5
if you capture with the pond then you
lose the bishop on d5 so Queen captures
this comes with Czech Knight captures we
Bishop captures Queen and c5 we have
captures on d5 captures on f5 and now a6
and although Rashid after now all is
said and done has a bishop and the night
for a rook
this is far from an ordinary endgame I
assure you King to F to rush it brings
his king over you know deeper into the
position rook H to g8 now comes a for
the Queen sir of the board but that's no
reason for Rashid not to attack be
captures an a4 and now rook captures an
A for King to b7 Baskin also tries to
bring his king over into the game now
comes Luke to be four would check King
to c6 and now what's the idea Rasheed
had why did he allow this what if he
checked the King so pink c6 will be
played if you go Bishop to e7 or
something then after after rook moves
you know black will simply exchange
pieces if you go Bishop to a7 black can
also simply attack the bishop if you go
back then black will of course trap your
bishop but a Rasheed's idea was
something completely different here
Rasheed played rock the b6 check and now
you see the problem here the only move
was to go back and then face a very
passive position a losing position I did
that but Baskin decided not nice to you
know suffer anymore he decided to
capture the bishop and now of course you
can all see it it's a very nice idea of
forced checkmate in three if you're
interested in some light
tactics feel free to pause the video and
you know try to find it so okay for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show night a for would
check the rock is guarded the only
square for the King our c4 and d4 King
c4 was played and now comes b3 with
check we have King before and now comes
her rook to before and this is checkmate
as now the King has nowhere to go
the knight is controlling c5 and c3 the
pony's controlling d3 the King is
controlling III and the rook of course
is controlling the entire fourth rank so
this is the game our signature Medina
versus V basking in 1948 Moldavia in
championship I do
do hope you enjoyed it and you know
always you know it's always a very
pleasant thing watching games of
Rashida's Medina so you know if you have
a friend who enjoys chess you know do
tell him about Roisin is Medina then
perhaps you know show him a game or two
played by
sheesh Mandino so he can also enjoy them
and also share Rasheed's games with his
friends and one day maybe if this
channel really grows into a big channel
then we're gonna do an official petition
to feed a at a grand Russian ajma'in of
the title of Grand Master and not the
owner everyone but the real one so yeah
that's that's you know an edge Medina of
game to brighten your day I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I'll see you tomorrow with
another Rashid game see you soon